oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
indeed it is a good afternoon good
afternoon please have a seat everybody
please have a seat thank you
feels good doesn't it
[Applause]
president biden
president obama
members of congress
and my fellow americans
on march 23 2010
the affordable care act was signed into
law
[Applause]
in the 12 years since the aca has
delivered high quality affordable health
care
to more than 30 million americans
yes
and those americans are working parents
and young children
college students and older americans
millions of people who had never been
able to afford coverage before
or who had been denied coverage
altogether
often because of a category of denial
called pre-existing
conditions conditions
such as cancer
diabetes
hypertension or even asthma
the aca is the most consequential
health care legislation
passed in generations in our country
[Applause]
and it is something more the aca is a
statement of purpose
a statement about the nation we must be
we're all people
no matter who they are
where they live or how much they earn
can access the health care they need no
matter the cost
you know when i served as attorney
general of california it was that
purpose
that led our office and 10 other state
attorneys general to submit a brief to
the united states supreme court in
defense of the aca and it is that
purpose
that brings us all together today
to continue to expand affordable health
care and its coverage to families across
our nation and to call on congress to
take action
to pass legislation
that simply allows medicare to directly
negotiate prescription drug prices with
pharmaceutical companies
[Applause]
and if there's any question why
i'll explain
more than 60 million americans are
enrolled in medicare
that would give medicare significant
bargaining power
to negotiate prices for all those
americans
so instead of forcing individual
patients
to negotiate by themselves
require them to pay whatever price the
drug companies set
they would have that kind of
representation
to stand there with their fellow
americans
and negotiate those prices so that they
would just simply be fair
so today we also call on congress to
make permanent the aca subsidies that
are included in the american rescue plan
[Applause]
subsidies that are currently lowering
insurance premiums for millions of
americans and which are set to expire in
december
and more must be done
currently
there are 12 states in our nation
that refuse to expand medicaid
for no reason
other than petty partisan obstruction
as a result
four million people in our country
are locked out of coverage
and that comes at a cost for example
women who do not have health care
coverage and are therefore less likely
to have access during pregnancy or
before or after to pelvic exams or
vaccinations prenatal checkups
postpartum depression screenings
and all the other essential care they
need
to be safe and healthy before during and
after birth
we know that expanding medicaid coverage
significantly reduces the number of
mothers who die as a result of pregnancy
so the sooner coverage is expanded in
those 12 states the more lives we will
save
protecting the health and well-being of
the people of our nation
should not be a partisan issue
every person in our nation
should be able to access and afford the
health care they need to thrive not as a
privilege but as a right
and that is why our administration will
continue to use every tool at our
disposal
to strengthen the aca
and with that
it is now
my great pleasure
to introduce the man whose vision and
leadership led us to this day whose
unwavering commitment to the people of
our nation laid the foundation for this
groundbreaking legislation
a leader who showed us the way forward
on this important issue please welcome
president barack obama
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you everybody have a seat
[Applause]
thank you
vice president biden
vice president
that was a joke
[Applause]
[Music]
that was all set up
my president joe biden vice president
harris
our dear friend
madam speaker nancy pelosi
uh all the members
of congress who are in attendance today
the members of cabinet
it is good to be back in the white house
um
it's been a while
i confess uh
i heard some changes had been made
by the current president since i was
last here
apparently secret service agents have to
wear aviator glasses now
the navy mess has been replaced by a
baskin robbins
and there's there's a cat running around
which i i guarantee you bo and sonny
would have been very unhappy about it
but
coming back even if i have to wear a tie
which i
very rarely do these days
gives me a chance to visit with some of
the incredible people
who serve this white house and who serve
this country every single day
a lot of times out of the limelight
they make
this government function and they help
people
in ways big and small
and and
from the outside sometimes
people don't understand
just how grueling this is and how many
sacrifices people make
because those of us who are in front of
the cameras oftentimes get the credit
but it's a lot of people
who are devoted day in day out
to making this country better that
matter and
a lot of them are represented here and
that's not just in the west wing by the
way it's also in the residence there
were a lot of people who looked after
our families
um
that i will always be grateful to so
it's wonderful to be back to say thank
you to all of you
but most of all
coming back here gives me a chance to
say
thank you and spend some time with an
extraordinary friend and partner who was
by my side for eight years
joe biden and i did a lot together
[Applause]
we helped save the global economy
made record investments in clean energy
we put guard rails
on our financial system we helped turn
the auto industry around
repeal don't ask don't tell
but nothing
made me prouder
than
providing better health care and more
protections to millions of people across
this country
so
so when president biden said he was not
going to just celebrate the aca but also
announce actions that would make it even
better
i had to show up
i think it's been well documented
just how difficult it was to pass the
aca there
there's
you can get a lot of testimony here uh
in case uh
folks haven't heard
you know as a country we have been
talking about
reforming health care for 100 years
unlike almost every other advanced
economy on earth we didn't have a system
that guaranteed access
to health care for all of its citizens
millions of people didn't have health
insurance
often because their employers didn't
provide it or because it was too
expensive
but despite the fact that our health
care system didn't work well
it was hard to change
healthcare represents about one-fifth of
our economy
that's trillions of dollars that are
involved so
there were a lot of
different economic interests
that were vying to maintain the status
quo
and because the majority of americans
did have health care
some people naturally worried that
they'd lose what they had
the media was skeptical of past failures
there was a lot of
misinformation to say the least flying
around
and uh
it's fair to say that most republicans
showed little interest in working with
us to get anything done
that's fair to say
but despite great odds
joe and i were determined
because we'd met too many people
on the campaign trail
who'd shared their stories
and our own families
had been touched by illness
and as i said to our dear friend harry
reid
who uh is missed
wished he was here today
because he took great pride in what we
did
i intended to get health care passed
even if it cost me re-election
which for a while looked like it might
but for all of us
for joe
for harry for nancy pelosi
for others
the aca was an example of why you run
for office in the first place why all of
you sign up for doing jobs that pay less
than you could make someplace else
while you're away from home sometimes
and you miss
some soccer practices or some dance
recitals
because we don't
we're not supposed to do this
just to occupy a seat
or
to hang on to
power
but we're supposed to do this because
it's making
a difference in the lives of the people
who sent us here
and because of so many people
including a lot of people who are here
today
made enormous sacrifices
because members of congress took
courageous votes
including some who
knew
that their vote would likely cost them
their seat
because the incredible leadership of
nancy and harry
we got the aca across the finishing
together
[Applause]
and the night we passed the aca i've
said it before it it was
a high point of my time here because it
reminded me and reminded us of what is
possible
but
of course our work was not finished
republicans tried to repeal what we had
done
again
and again
and again
and they found lawsuits that went all
the way to the supreme court
three times i see don varela here who
had to defend
a couple of them
[Applause]
they tried explicitly to make it harder
for people to sign up for coverage
uh and let's face it it didn't help that
when we first rolled out the aca the
website didn't work
that was not one of my happiest moments
so given all the noise and the
controversy and the skepticism it took a
while for the american people to
understand what we had done
but lo and behold
a little later than i'd expected
a lot of folks
including
many who had initially opposed health
care reform came around
and today the aca hasn't just survived
it's pretty darn popular
and the reason is because
it's done what it was supposed to do
it's made a difference
first 20 million
and now 30 million people
have gotten covered thanks to the aca
it's
it's prevented insurance companies from
denying people coverage based on a
pre-existing condition
it's lowered prescription drug costs for
12 million seniors
it's allowed young people to
stay on their parents plan until they're
26.
it's eliminated lifetime limits on
benefits but often put people in a jam
so we are incredibly proud of that work
but
the reason we're here today is because
president biden vice president harris
everybody who's worked on this thing
understood from the start that the aca
wasn't perfect
to get the bill passed
we had to make compromises
we didn't get everything we wanted
that wasn't a reason not to do it
if you can get
millions of people health coverage and
better production
it is to quote a famous american a
pretty
big deal
[Applause]
but there were gaps to be filled
even today some patients
still pay too much for their
prescriptions
some poor americans are still falling
through the cracks
in some cases healthcare subsidies
aren't where we want them to be
which means that some working families
are still having trouble
paying for their coverage
here's the thing that's not unusual when
we make major progress in this country
the original social security act
left out entire categories of people
like domestic workers and farm workers
that had to be changed
in the beginning medicare didn't provide
all the benefits that it does today that
had to be changed
history what you see is
that it's important to get something
started to plan a flag to lay a
foundation
for further progress
the analogy i've used
about the aca before is that in the same
way that
was true for early forms of social
security medicare it was a starter home
it secured the principle of universal
health care provided help immediately to
families
but it required us to continually build
on it
and make it better
and president biden understands that
and that's what he's done
since the day he took office
as part of the american rescue plan he
lowered the cost of health care even
further for millions of people
he made signing up easier
made outreach to those who didn't know
they could get covered
make sure that they knew made that a
priority
and as a result of these actions he
helped a record
14.5 million americans get covered
during the most recent enrollment period
[Applause]
that ladies and gentlemen is what
happens when you have an administration
that's committed to making a program
work
and today
today the biden harris administration is
going even further
by moving to fix a glitch
in the regulations that will lower
premiums for nearly 1 million people who
need it and allow 200 000 more
uninsured americans get access to
coverage
i'm a private citizen now
but i still take it
more than a passing interest in the
course of our democracy
but i'm outside the arena and and i know
how discouraged people can get with
washington
democrats republicans independents
everybody feels frustrated sometimes
about
what takes place in this town
progress feels
way too slow sometimes
victories are often incomplete
and in a country as big and as diverse
as ours consensus never comes easily
but what the affordable care act shows
is that you are driven
by the core idea
that together
we can improve the lives
of this generation and the next
and if you're persistent
if you stay with it and are willing to
work through the obstacles
and the criticism
and continually improve where you fall
short
you can make america better
you can have an impact on millions
of lives
you can help make sure folks don't have
to lose their homes when they get sick
that they don't have to worry
whether a loved one is going to get
the treatment they need
joe biden understands that
he has dedicated his life to the
proposition that there's something
worthy about public service
and that the reason to run for office
is for days like today
so i could not be more honored to be
here with him as he writes the next
chapter in our story of progress
i'm grateful for all the people who've
been involved in continuing to make
the aca everything it can be
and it is now my great privilege to
introduce
the 46th president of the united states
joe biden
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much please
my name is joe biden i'm barack obama's
vice president
and i'm jill biden's husband
by the way the only reason jill's not
here today
she's working
she's teaching
and so i just want you know that's why
she's not here good afternoon everyone
mr president welcome back to the white
house man feels like the good old days
being here with you
brings back so many good memories we
just had lunch together and we weren't
sure who was just supposed to sit where
look it's fitting that the first time
you return to the white house
is to celebrate a law a law that's
transforming millions of lives because
of you
and i say because of you we had a lot of
help the staff and i helped a little bit
was because of you
a law that shows hope leads to change
and you did that
you did it let's be honest
the affordable care act
has been called a lot of things
but obamacare is the most fitting
obamacare
[Laughter]
i can tell you all how much barack obama
cared about getting this done
throughout the countless hours of
negotiations and the relentless
political attacks he never ever ever
gave up and i guarantee you that
if i had time i could tell you all the
times when he'd say should we compromise
should we do and i'd say well we ought
to think about that no if i do that then
so-and-so won't get covered this group
of people won't get covered
whether it was after
meeting our our
during our weekly lunch and we met every
single day
he'd remind me of what we're why we're
doing this in the first place
we're doing this in the first place for
people who needed it and deserve to be
treated with dignity
dignity
the idea that when you can't afford
health insurance for your children
your spouse male or female
it doesn't matter
not only are they in trouble but you're
deprived of your dignity
barack you talked about the idea that
was important
that we make sure that you couldn't
outrun your insurance
i can remember there with
with bo thinking to myself
what would i do
if they walked in and said you've outrun
your timing
and there were still
35 days to live
the things that changed people's lives
we both understood
the affordable care act wasn't about a
single president or the presidency
it was about the countless
countless americans lying in bed at
night
staring at the ceiling wondering my god
my god what if i get really sick
what am i going to do what are my family
going to do
or i lose the house
discussions we had in my house with my
dad
when he lost his health insurance
who's going to pay for it
who's going to take care of my family
you know
in america
healthcare as we all three said will
have now said healthcare should be right
not a privilege
and
[Applause]
with with the help of members of
congress especially nancy
and the advocates for families are here
today
12 years ago last month 12 years ago
we made a good effort
toward that proposition it should be
right
when uh in barack when you signed the
affordable care act in law
it became the most consequential piece
of health insurance
that most consequential piece of
legislation in my view
since creation of medicare medicaid in
1965.
it made a difference in people's lives
every day
he just talked about where we were
before the affordable care act and what
happened in the past 12 years
to make a life a lot better for people
i'd like to talk about where we go from
here
because because we knew back then as
brock as the president said
we knew that we had to keep
strengthening this legislation
look
that's why i ran for president and i
promised to protect and build upon the
affordable care act
as soon as entered office did exactly
what kamala and i did
and what our administration
and the democrats in congress here today
did
we pass the landmark american rescue
plan
which not only helped us in the covet 19
get it under control
and our economy back on track
it got millions more people
insured under the affordable care act
it made it easier for people to sign up
for coverage in the middle of a
pandemic it opened a special enrollment
people and gave millions and millions of
americans
more time to enroll
it quadrupled the number of navigators
out there in the communities helping
people to sign up for coverage because
confusing the people
it's confusing
presidents heard me say we work together
you know they'd say well biden and obama
are doing great on foreign policies you
want to do something difficult try
health
care not a joke
not a joke
so we continue to expand medicaid
missouri and oklahoma became the 37 and
38 states to expand medicaid under the
affordable care act
[Applause]
has been mentioned over 31 million
people now have health insurance through
the affordable care act
four out of five americans
can find quality coverage for under ten
dollars a month
the average family
the average family is saving two
thousand four hundred dollars a year on
their premiums
that's 200 every single month
available for other needs in their lives
from gas to groceries to other basic
necessities
the bottom line is this the affordable
care act is stronger now than it has
ever been
and today
[Applause]
now i'm not even talking about what your
former chief of staff is doing to make
sure health care is available all our
veterans are the way to do it yeah
today
we're strengthening even further
in a moment i'm going to sign an
executive order building on one of those
that i signed last year
it directs federal agencies to
continuing everything in their power
everything in their power to expand
quality and affordable health care
coverage
making it easier people to enroll in and
keep their coverage
helping people better understand their
coverage options and to pick to be able
to pick the best option for that family
taking steps to strengthen benefits
lower costs and expand eligibility
protecting americans
from low quality coverage that can lead
to a mountain of medical debt
and folks
and separately it's time to fix what we
refer to as the family glitch
now the family glitch although everybody
in this room probably knows what it is
but it's a common issue
facing five million americans who can't
get financial help to get coverage under
the affordable care act here's the
problem under the current rules a
working mom is told
as long as she can afford employer-based
coverage for herself
she can't qualify
for premium subsidies to afford coverage
for her family cover her
but not her family
we're working to change that
once today's proposed rule is finalized
starting next year working families
in america
will get the help they need to afford
full
family coverage everyone in the family
[Applause]
bad
as a result as a result families will be
saving hundreds of dollars a month
with this change it's estimated that 200
000
presently uninsured americans are going
to gain coverage
nearly 1 million americans
will see their coverage become more
affordable
this is considered one of the biggest
things my administration can do lower
cost and expand coverage
we're taking steps today to get that
done so look folks but we need we need
to keep up the fight
our republican colleagues
as they say in southern zelda haven't
changed a whole hell of a lot
good folks but haven't changed a lot
they continue to attack the affordable
care act
they're unrelenting
unrelenting
they haven't stopped mr president since
you signed the law they haven't stopped
for one
second multiple court challenges you
mentioned sabotage from the previous
administration
over 70 attempts
to repeal the law by republicans in
congress
in fact
just last month
the distinguished senator from wisconsin
said
if republicans get back in power
they should try to repeal the affordable
care act again
again try
today
12 years later republicans have not
stopped their attacks on this
life-saving law
so pay very close attention folks
if republicans have their way
it means 100 million americans with
pre-existing conditions
can once again be night health care
coverage by their insurance companies
that's what the law was before obamacare
in addition
tens of millions of americans could lose
their coverage including young people
will no longer be able to stay on their
parents insurance policy that age 26.
premiums are going to go through the
roof
well i got a better idea
instead of destroying the affordable
care act let's keep building on it
let's extend it
stand
because
of all the
all the folks in this room members of
congress the american rescue plan
subsidies uh
subsidizes that are lowering premium
subsidies lowering premiums and
extending coverage and uh
i got a little practice when you gave me
the other actors you know when we were
president
you were president i was with you
look
close the medicaid
coverage gap that locks nearly 4 million
americans out of coverage just because
their states refuse to expand medicaid
lower prescription drug costs which is
mentioned already by allowing medicare
to negotiate prices for drugs that are
on the market
we can do this
we should do this we have to do this
but let me close with this
12 years ago
at a bill signing the affordable care
act president obama said quote
we're a nation that does what is hard
what is necessary and what is right
that's exactly what he did
exactly what he did
and folks
that's what we have to do as we do as
americans
you know
it's what all of you did here in making
the affordable care act possible i
really mean it
we just keep it we just got to keep it
going and keep building on it we need to
keep the faith
we need to remember
we're the united states of america
and there's simply literally nothing
beyond our capacity
when we're united and do it together
so god bless you all may god protect our
troops and now
i'm going to sign an executive order
and barack let me remind you
it's a hot mic
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
everybody
i have to admit one thing i haven't
gotten down
barack obama could sign his name using
nine different pens
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
leaving them out of space
[Music]
[Music]
um
hey guys
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
actually
i don't know how he's working happy
[Music]
what's happening in ukraine that you
rethink your decision mr president
[Music]
[Music]
president at what point
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
i don't think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah i think we can break down